I'm actually going to continue here.
One of the discussions that I
had begun in the last lecture,
which,
uh,
which involved the matter
of the relationship of this
poem paradise regained to
the earlier epic, uh, which we,
we have to acknowledge is on so many ways
the more ambitious poem paradise lost.
And so I want to look at the way
in which Milton uses this new poem,
Paradise regained to explore the larger,
the larger problem of identity.
Um,
and a lot of ways the identity of
Milton himself, Milton's identity as a,
an obedient son of God. Uh,
Milton's identity as a, as a poet.
Um, and, and all, all of this gets
worked out over the course of the,
over the course of the,
of the poem,
each of the characters in paradise
regained Satan and the sun,
each of them is involved
in an elaborate process.
And it's really a process that
spans the entire poem, um,
of trying to figure out
who the other one is.
And on top of that,
each of them is trying to figure
out who he himself is or who he,
uh, or who he himself has
been in the son's case.
Um, there's that, uh,
turn, I don't know what
page this is on book one,
lines three 55 and 56.
This is the sun speaking
to Satan. And, uh,
I think it's an extraordinary thing
for the son to say, um, book one,
line three 55,
the son says to Satan,
why dust thou then suggest to me distrust,
knowing who I am as I know who thou art.
Why does style then
suggest to me distrust,
knowing who I am as I know who thou art.
And of course we are, how can we not? Um,
we are inclined to assume that
because this is the son of God.
After all that this is,
that there's,
that there's something more meaningful
about this statement then actually is the
case. What does the sun
know? The Sun does know, uh,
that Satan is his enemy and that Satan
is of that to be identified with that
serpent from the pro Evangelian.
The prophecy back in Genesis, um,
who it will be the son's job to destroy.
The son knows that,
um,
and Satan knows
that the son is his enemy and that it
will be the son's job as the Messiah to g
to destroy him.
But this is still just a partial knowledge
and it's remarkable the extent to
which Milton doesn't let on just
how partial this knowledge is.
We don't know it until the end,
how little the sun and Satan actually
understand about themselves and about each
other.
And so I think the sun is actually wrong
in some way at this early point in the
poem to claim that he knows who Satan is
because his is of course just a partial
knowledge and Satan doesn't know fully
who the son is. Um, and the, and
the sun doesn't know fully who,
whose who Satan is.
And each of them,
each of them on some level knows
who the other is. But each,
but neither of them knows who
the other had been. If that,
I'm hoping that will make more sense
by the time we get to the end of the,
the end of our period here. Okay.
So what, what little action,
uh, what little drama this, this poem
of affords us and it is, you know,
we have to confess it is, it is relatively
little, um, involves justice struggle,
this intellectual struggle
to understand one's identity.
And I think that that the search for
identity represented and the poem in a lot
of ways is a reflection of or something
like a narrative version of Milton's own
attempts. And we've been, we've been
tracking this for a long time now.
Milton's own attempts to identify himself.
So one of the questions I think at
stake here is who is John Milton?
Who is this man?
Who is this man who dared to rewrite
scripture in his 12th book epic poem.
Paradise lost this,
this,
I think this poem is everywhere trying
to answer that question and it begins
answering it at the,
at the very opening look,
look at the beginning of
paradise regained. This is
page four 83 in the Hughes
I,
and obviously this is a Milton,
the narrator talking to us,
I whoever,
while the happy garden song by one man's
disobedience lost now seeing recovered
paradise to all mankind by
one man's from obedience,
fully tried.
And,
and obviously Milton is drawing our
attention to, to the earlier achievement,
the epic that had begun with
that prepositional phrase, uh,
of man's first disobedience.
And so the poet very carefully rings a
variation on that phrase in the forest
line of the new poem and the new,
the new phrases by one
man's from obedience.
And this little modulation reflects,
of course, the change of, of,
of subject matter. Uh, but, but look
at the way in which Milton has, it's,
this is unbelievable to me.
Look at how he has characterized
his authorship of the earlier poem.
I who air while the Happy Garden Song?
No,
just just,
just pause for a moment and think about
what kind of way that is to refer to
the, the, the magnificent
epic achievement that is,
that is paradise lost.
Milton's diluting and these [inaudible],
he hasn't made up this convention.
He's alluding and these lines to the
opening of Virgil's epic, the Aeneid,
and also to the beginning
of Spencer's romance epic,
the Fairy Queen and Spencer of course,
was himself alluding to Virgil and Virgil
and Spencer had begun their vast and
ambitious literary projects by
identifying themselves to the readers. Um,
and so each of them in his way,
uh,
began their huge poems like,
like this I the poet who
had sung of happy gardens,
who had been content
writing pastoral poems,
diminutive little pastoral lyrics.
I'm now embarking on an epic and an epic.
As you all know,
from having read homer is a poem
that treats of heroism and of war.
I have graduated to epic ambition.
That's how Spencer began the fairy queen.
And that's how a virtual before
him had begun the Aeneid.
And by the time we get to the renaissance,
this is really the standard way
of introducing your epic poem.
Okay,
that's fine.
But what sense one sentence is there
to Milton's beginning paradise regained
this way, this, he should have done this.
He should have done this
before in paradise lost.
What sense does it make from Milton to
begin this poem with that conventional
epic opening?
Milton had already written his epic and
not only had Milton already written as
epic,
but he had written his diminutive little
pastoral lyrics long before that I'd
say maybe 30 years, uh, before
the publication of Paradise,
a paradise regained. Listen
to us, uh, comas led,
grow and heal pencil aroso.
Those were Milton's pastoral poems.
Those were the poems in which he,
he's saying the happy garden,
but to identify paradise lost as a,
as a simple pastoral about a happy garden
is obviously on some level to get it
wrong.
And,
and I think there's everything riding on
the fact that Milton has misidentified
the nature of his paradise lost. And, and,
and so this is going to be the working
assumption of the rest of this lecture
that Milton,
on some level,
and I know this sounds farfetched,
that Milton has repressed the
epic content of his epic poem.
Now you'll remember that last time we
saw how Satan and paradise regained,
had repressed the fact that it was in
fact the son of God who had brought him to
the brink of destruction
during the war in heaven.
He had repressed a crucial
fact about that war,
the most crucial fact about that
more. Well, and on some level,
the speaker of the poem, Milton's
narrator, we can call him Milton,
um,
joins Satan in this act of repression.
And the speaker of this poem has ref
repressed the fact of the war in heaven as
well.
It's as if he had forgotten that paradise
lost was an epic something more than a
poem merely about a happy
garden because in epic, um,
necessarily features that
the epic subject of, of war,
um,
paradise lost,
can't be identified
merely with book for the,
our introduction to the garden of
Eden. Needless to say, um, it's not,
it's not just the paradise
lost featured, uh, that lush,
a extraordinarily beautiful style of
poetry that Milton fields in some way,
he has to resist in paradise regained.
It's not just the lure of
the rich classical style.
That was so tempting there.
It's,
it's also the fact that paradise lost
represented, gave us an image of,
of heroic actions and the heroic
actions of its characters.
It's characters actually
did something, uh, uh,
fact that we didn't know we were supposed
to appreciate so much when we were
actually reading the thing. But now that
we're reading paradise regained, um,
the fact that the characters
actually act and do in paradise lost,
um,
takes on a new meaning.
And the very fact of all of that action
that had been represented in paradise
lost has become something of a problem
by the time we get to paradise regained.
Now we remember that, uh, that,
that when Milton in those early poems
was considering his problems of,
of career and a vocation,
he was consistently imagining a tension
between those two parables. Uh, it, the,
the, those two parables in the
gospel of Matthew that posed,
that posed the question of action,
the question of work and the
parable of the talents. This
is, you know, this, this,
this,
this lecture in some way will be
something like a review session for the,
for the whole,
for the whole semester up to this point,
the parable of the talents suggested
that hard work and initiative were
absolutely essential for
the father's approval.
While the parable of the workers in
the vineyard gave us a different,
gave it to a different understanding,
suggested in some way that the father
approves of the individual who's willing
merely to wait to be called to work.
And the conflicting or what seemed to
be the conflicting implications of those
two parables were worked
over and dozens of,
of earlier poems and in prose treatises
and their reworked here in paradise,
regain again much later
in Milton's career. Um,
and there, there, there, there,
there reworked and the three temptations
that the son of God undergoes at the
hand of Satan and in paradise regained.
So this for me is one of the most amazing
and most surprising aspects of Satan's
temptation of the son of God.
In this poem in Paradise,
Paradise lost.
Satan had tempted eve to be disobedient.
And it was clear to everyone that
this was a kind of temptation to evil.
But this, this is the situation
in a paradise regained.
This is a much more complicated poem
and uh, it's infinitely more complex.
The nature of these temptations of Satan
in this poem is tempting the Sun not to
act disobediently,
but on some level actually to act
virtuously or what strikes us as,
as a virtuous behavior.
Now the cardinal and the cardinal virtues,
um, you'll remember from an earlier
discussion of comas are faith,
hope and charity and, and in
Milton's account, and it's ingenious,
I'm Satan tempts the
sun with those virtues,
but he does it in precisely
the reverse order.
He temps to son to an act of charity and
then to an act of hope and then an act
of faith.
Now just,
just think of what Milton does
to the original story in Luke.
Okay.
So the sun is,
is hungry after 40 days
fasting in the wilderness.
Now in the account from
the gospel of Luke,
Satan responds to the sun's hunger by
tempting him to turn this stone into
bread.
He's tempting him to provide
himself with something to eat.
Well. Uh, Milton, uh,
it goes way beyond that and in paradise
regained Satan doesn't merely tempt the
son of God to eat something himself that
would be far too easy for the sun to
resist.
He asks us under turn the stone into
bread so he can perform the virtuous,
that charitable act of feeding the hungry.
And if feeding the poor,
we're starving here.
Satan tells a disguise.
Satan tells us,
tells the Sun.
And in a magnificent line that strikes
me as as perfectly prophetic of the Vegan
movement of the late 20th
century, Satan says, uh,
sublimely we hear live
on tough roots and stubs.
We hear live on tough roots and stubs.
This is the kind of,
I don't know if you get those emails
that I get from a woman named Anastasia
curly from the sustainable food
project, but I think of her, um,
with those updates from what's happening
at the farm. Um, when I read this line,
we hear live on tough brutes and Stubbs
and we're asking for your help. Uh,
that's, that's what Satan
says. And it's this temptation,
the temptation to virtuous action
that the sun has to resist.
It's not a simple,
simple temptation to gluttony in any
way as it seems to be in the Gospel.
Original Satan is tempting the son
what to exhibit a little humanity to,
you know, just to do the right thing. Uh,
milk Milton's father John Milton senior
had pressed the young Milton to s to
stop reading at home and to begin
doing something. Uh, he was,
his father was pressuring
Milton to perform. The Virtue
is action of a clergyman.
Um, and it was just this form of
virtuous action that Milton, of course,
as we remember this,
was continually resisting and he insisted
repeatedly that he wasn't ready yet.
He wasn't ready to start acting.
It's too soon.
We found him a continually protesting.
I'm not ripe yet.
And it was at, and he was
constantly explaining to that, uh,
to that paternal authority that he had
in some way internalized. Um, the, the,
the fact of his unrighteousness.
And of course it seems to be something
just like the voice of Milton's father
and in Milton,
which is nothing less than or nothing
other than Milton's own conscience that
constitutes the essence
of the next temptation.
And that's the attempt [inaudible] to
accept the worldly kingdoms from Satan as
Satan's gift.
And it's the second temptation,
which really takes up the bulk of the
poem, um, and the Milton and takes this,
this verse from the Gospel of Luke and
explodes it and to hundreds and hundreds
of lines. And it stretches from the middle
of book, two to the middle of book for,
and it's here that Milton most
really most powerfully distorts his,
his scriptural source. He takes, you know,
what you could think
of as a kind of brief,
throwaway temptation
from the gospel of Luke.
And he expands it into a set
of several sub temptations and,
and they're genuine temptations. And
in a lot of ways he's imported. Um,
the,
the notion of these temptations from his
favorite can't to of the fairy queen,
the Cave of Mammon Canto from book two.
So Milton takes its cue from Spencer and
transforms this tech second temptation
into,
into a catalog of all of those activities,
all of those seemingly virtuous
activities that he had himself,
that he had himself
devoted his life to that.
And so this massive and endlessly
seemingly endlessly elaborated second
temptation,
weeds,
something like Milton's autobiography.
Um,
he explores with what I take to
be an almost painful precision.
The central drives and the impulses of,
of his very,
of his very being of Satan tempts
the son of God with wealth. Uh,
W he tends to the son of God with,
with revolutionary political commitment,
with the promise of military success.
He offers Jesus the entire Parthian army
to help him regain the throne of David.
Because of course,
everybody knows Jesus will eventually
regain the throne of David. Um, he sent,
he tempts the sun with empire.
He offers to give him a,
the empire of Rome since the current
Emperor Tiberius is so old and corrupt
anyway.
And,
and he tempts him finally with all of
the beauty and all of the wisdom and all
of the fame associated with classical,
classical Athens.
In short,
um,
Satan tempts the sun with just about
everything that was ever important to,
to two hour John Milton.
And it's almost as if Milton
had deliberately structured
the second temptation
is something like a review
session for the Milton exam.
You have an entire career,
Neri career narrated here.
So in the temptation to wealth,
and I've given you a sense of the dates,
but it's also on your handout. Um,
and the temptation to wealth. You have
the protestations of action and, and,
and of merit that guilty
defensiveness that you,
that you saw on the lyrics of the 1630s.
And in that Latin poem,
I'd pop time that Milton had written
to his father in the temptation to
political commitment, um, or the
temptation to intervene politically. Um,
you have Milton's new commitment,
the commitment of the 1640,
the decade of his prose to apply
his literary energies, uh, to,
to do the goal of the puritan revolution,
the desire to reform the corruption
of church, Church and state,
and the temptation in the temptation
to Parthian military glory.
You can hear Milton's con conviction
and the regicide treatises of 1649 and
there abouts his conviction in the,
the importance of destroying,
destroying with force by actual
military power, the unlawful tear,
any of Charles the first.
And in the temptation of the
Roman Empire, you have the,
the reflected the faith that Milton
seemed to hold and the early 1650s,
at least in the almost unlimited utopian
potential of the Puritan Commonwealth,
the hope, and it was, it turned out to
be a crazy and perfectly irrational hope,
but the hope that an empire governed
by the virtuous puritan saints might
actually be able to precipitate the
millennium or the apocalypse at the end of
time.
And in the last,
in the last part of
Satan's second temptation,
Satan's absolutely delicious
and completely irresistible
offer of literary fame
and classical wisdom,
uh,
in the form of classical Athens.
Uh,
clearly this last addition to the
separate second temptation that was the,
the, is the, is the thing
that persists throughout,
throughout Milton's career. It,
it, it, it obviously
spans his entire life.
So Milton alludes to and recycles
in the elaborated second temptation.
All of the virtuous commitments and all
of the discipline decisions that he had
been making himself over the
course of the last 40 years.
And he presents them in. This is what's
so brilliant. He presents them in the form
that the hero has to
resist the temptations,
that the hero has to resist the
voices in his head that had been, uh,
that had come to him and through the,
through the mechanism of conscience
or God or John Milton senior or some,
someone authoritative,
um,
all of those authoritative voices are
now crystallized in the person and the
shape of, of, of Satan.
And Satan is tempting to son of God
with a version of essentially all of the
virtuous behavior that Milton's
father had pressured Milton width.
Now it's usually clear that the sate,
that Satanic version,
and this is almost always clear that the
satanic version is of the temptation is
an evil or at least a
questionable rendition of the
virtuous action that Milton
himself had over the course of
those years felt obliged to perform.
But it's not always perfectly
clear to me as, as a, as a reader,
um, why it is that all of
Satan's arguments are faulty or,
or why it is we have to dismiss
them necessarily as, as evil.
And it often seems that the son of God
is rejecting modes of action and types of
virtuous commitment that,
that Milton himself actively
embraced. And, and, and,
and there's nothing which,
which is just a way of saying there's,
there's nothing that mill Milton is
not willing to question, um, in this,
in this poem. Um, he's,
he's struggling to reinterpret in some
way his entire career as if to purify it.
Um, have anything like a
self interested motive.
It's as if he's systematically reviewing,
scrutinizing every move,
every type of action that he had been gay,
engaged in over the years in order to
purify his own past by differentiating it
in some way from, from it's satanic
double from a dark version of, uh,
of, of his own virtue. Okay,
let's turn to page 510 in the Hughes.
This is book three,
line two 24.
And this is a good example of the way
in which Milton will cast as a satanic
temptation,
the voice of virtuous conscience that
had plagued him as a younger man. So, uh,
so Satan asks, if you have such hopes
to be the savior of your nation,
of course you do. Why don't you hurry
up and act, come on, do something.
Look at line two 24.
Uh,
why move by feet so slow to what is best?
And I'll skip a couple of lines here.
Perhaps they'll linguist in deep
thoughts detained of the enterprise.
So hazardous in high.
No wonder for though in the United would
have perfect cannon man be found or
human nature can receive.
Consider thy life have yet been private.
It's a,
it's a quite a jab.
You're not, you're not,
you're not really fit
for public action at all.
Consider the life have yet been private.
Most part spent at home scarce
viewed the Galilean towns and,
and once a year Jerusalem. Oh, I,
it's saint and saying, Oh, I know why
you're hesitant to act. You're too busy.
Lingering in all of your deep thoughts.
You've spent all of your life at
home and you've never ventured out.
You've never sallied forth
to do something in the world.
And Milton has incorporated
into Satan's temptation,
a piercing critique of his own tendency,
that early tendency to wait to
anticipate rather than to act.
And Satan tempts the sun with the wisdom
of John Milton's senior. Um, you're,
you've spent most of your life in private,
at home reading why in God's name,
don't you do something?
Now,
let's jump ahead to the final
moment of the second temptation,
which is another of Milton's
additions, uh, to the,
to the story that has absolutely
no basis in scripture whatsoever.
And, and of course its
absence from Milton's biblical
source should only draw our
attention all the more to its importance.
And this is the temptation to the
intellectual fame represented by classical
Athens. In book four, uh, turn to
book four line two 40
Satan displays before the sun, all of
the cultural wealth of ancient Athens.
And at line two 40 heat,
he invokes Athens,
the eye of Greece,
mother of Arts and eloquence.
And this Athens,
the mother of arts seems to possess within
it all of the classical learning that
Milton himself had been
addicted to a as a young man,
as he spent those years after
college in studious retirement,
as at his family's house, I
looked, looked down at line two 81,
uh,
the Satan urges the son to read
all of these great classical texts.
This is just getting so close to home.
A Satan says to the son,
these here revolve,
or as thou likes at home,
it's,
this is amazing.
He says,
if Satan and we're imagining
something like a lending library, um,
and nothing could be more attempting
to Milton the Sun could actually think
about read and ponder these works
in the privacy of his own home.
This, this line here convinces
me that Milton himself,
uh, had an enormous book collection. The
books were his, he read them at home. Um,
he, after, after he was in college, um,
he wasn't merely a reading them in an
old woman's house or a friend's copy or,
or in a, or in some
version of a library. Um,
Milton must have read at home
till tie these here revolve.
Or as they'll like stay at home till time,
maturity to a kingdoms weight.
These rules will render the king complete
within myself much more with empire
joined and, and, and, and,
and this temptation to immerse himself
in Pagan literature at home of course,
is the temptation that
in paradise or again,
that has to be most difficult
for Milton to imagine resisting.
Um, and, and, and, and of course it's,
I think it's the most difficult
temptation for us as readers to, to,
to encounter. Um, it's impossible in fact,
to read the son's response to Satan's
temptation here without wincing,
uh,
without wincing at the pain that had to
have accompanied Milton's writing of it.
This is the son who becomes unbelievably
puritanical at this point in a
stereotypical sense.
This is the top of page five
23 line three 22 of book for
the son says to Satan,
who reads incessantly and to his reading
brings not a spirit and judgment equal
or superior and what he brings,
what need he elsewhere seek,
uncertain and unsettled still remains
deep versed in books and shallow and
himself crude or intoxicate collecting
toys and trifles for choice matters worth
a sponge.
A sponge is an eraser as as try collecting
toys and trifles for choice matters
worth a sponge as children
gathering pebbles on the shore,
the sun dismisses dismisses literature.
He dismisses all of secular learning as
mirror toys fit for for children and you
can hear them and then you
can hear something like the
voice of Milton's father
here accusing Milton of childishness.
And you can also see here the important
association of literature with the
domestic sphere,
the space of the home,
the sphere of experience that's
governed not by the child's father,
but by the child's mother.
And it's important,
I think that Athens is very carefully
figured by Milton as the mother of arts
because this kind of learning is presented
and represented in Milton's poem is a
maternal inheritance and it's just this
maternal inheritance that the sun has to
resist because what's his, what's his
purpose here in this poem? It's perfect.
Uh,
s a sole obedience to the father.
The Sun's rejection of classical
learning really paralyzed, uh,
parallels Milton's Milton's own as he
writes this very poem on some level he's
describing for us what
he himself is doing.
He's obviously resisting
classical literature,
at least that illusion to
classical literature throughout
paradise regained. Um,
this poem is almost,
and of course I can only say almost,
it's almost scoured of,
of any classical references whatsoever.
Well,
the exquisitely abstemious son of God
resists this most tempting of temptations
just as he's resistant all the
others. And you know, this is the,
this is the big gun that Satan has just
pulled out and Satan understandably is
beside himself with frustration.
Look at line three 66 top of page five,
Satan quite at a loss for
all his darts were spent.
Satan has nothing else to ask.
But this astonishing
question at line three 72
look at Satan's question at line three 72
what dust dow in this world,
what does though in this world you have
rejected every form of action and I
can't imagine that you're actually willing
to do anything. This is ridiculous.
Can you do anything but say no?
The Satan asks the Sun.
But what of course Satan
doesn't understand yet is
that this poem isn't about
action. It's not about doing,
but on some important level.
It's about knowledge and particularly
it's about self, self knowledge.
And it's the problem of knowledge that
really comes to the fore at the third and
final temptation
which goes like this.
If you are, as you claim the
real son of God, then prove it.
Satan challenges the sun.
And so the,
the third temptation is essentially
a paternity test. Um, it's a,
it's a test in his faith
and who his father is.
And Satan's coming to the point where
he has to learn once and for all exactly
who this sun is.
And,
and it's here that Satan takes
us under the top of the pinnacle,
the father's house, the uh, uh,
that the top of the temple to prove that
he is in fact a son of God and Satan is
going back.
He's returning once again
to that proclamation that
the father had made it the
baptism.
This is my beloved son and
he has to figure out once
and for all what that meant.
So look at line five 27 no,
a look at page five 27. This
is book four, Line Five,
15 Satan to the sun.
I want to learn in what degree or
meaning thou art called the Son of God,
which bears no single sense.
The son of God.
I also am or was.
And if I was,
I am
okay.
Relation stands,
the son of God.
I also am or was.
And if I was,
I am relations stands the
relation of past and present.
The relation of,
of who I was to who I am is,
is finally presented here explicitly.
This is the big question and it's here
that the extent of what we can think of
is Satan's repression,
uh,
becomes almost unbearable
for me to witness.
He,
uh,
Satan insists that the son of God is a
term that can be used indiscriminately to
describe all of God's human and,
and angelic creatures.
And you know, he's right. Uh,
it was used pretty much indiscriminately,
um, throughout a lot of,
of paradise lost.
And Satan is incapable here
of acknowledging to himself
the identity of this son
of God, this opponent with that
son of God, the son of God.
That's so the so called only be gotten
the first big gotten in heaven way back
when that son of God,
whose favor in the eyes of the father
had of course motivated Satan's fall from
heaven. And the first place
had motivated the rebellion.
Satan brings the sun to the top of
the temple and he asks the sun to cast
himself down.
And it's,
it's incredible the degree to which this
climactic moment in this poem reworks,
that climactic moment in the
other poem from the war in Heaven,
in, in, in, in, in paradise lost.
It's as if unconsciously Satan is
trying to restage that fall from heaven.
Perhaps I am some sort of fantasy way
perhaps to have it have a different
outcome,
that terrible moment at which the sun
had successfully maneuvered Satan and the
other rebel angels into casting
themselves down from down from heaven.
Uh, it's a, it's a,
it's as if this were a desperate
attempt to Redo a traumatic moment.
Um, in the, in the familial past.
Satan tempts the son to call
upon the father to lift him up.
Since it is written in scripture that
angels will rush to the aid of the son of
the son of God.
So in essence,
if you are in fact the son of God prove
it, call upon the father to help you.
And it's at this point in Milton's text
that absolutely everything that we've
been discussing comes to a head.
It's a remarkable convergence.
Look at line five 60 on page five,
to whom thus Jesus also,
it is written tempt the Lord thy God.
He said and stood,
but Satan smitten with amazement,
fell.
The son of God performs no action
here other than quoting a verse,
a verse from the book of Deuteronomy,
and then stands,
or maybe actually just remains standing.
He refuses to honor Satan's request.
And, and he exhibits his complete
and total obedience to the father by,
by quoting the father's word, by quoting
scripture temp, not the Lord thy God.
And it's at this point,
and it is not before this point,
that the truth of the son's identity
becomes evident to Satan, I think.
Um,
and I think this is also the moment at
which the truth of the son's identity
becomes a parent also to the sun on.
On one level,
Jesus is merely, merely means,
don't tempt the Lord to, you know,
don't tempt the Lord thy God.
Don't tempt the Lord to help you
if you don't really need his help,
if you can do it on your own.
But at the very moment that the
sun quotes the father's scripture,
it's almost as if the meaning of this
scriptural verse, uh, Changes, uh,
before her very eyes temp,
not the Lord thy God comes also to mean
maybe by the time he's gotten to the
God.
Uh,
it comes also to mean perhaps don't tempt
me because I am in some way the Lord
thy God. And at this, and at this
very moment of absolute obedience,
the sun is rewarded with
the knowledge that he has,
not only the savior or the Messiah,
he's known that he's
rewarded with the knowledge,
that in some sense he is God's.
He has got himself.
It's an, it's an incredible moment
and it's at this moment that it's,
it's as if the repression,
this poem's repression of Paradise
lost the earlier poem has been lifted.
The repression that is obscured,
the identity of this son of
God with that son of God,
the son of God who was actually
responsible for driving
out Satan from heaven in
the first place.
The repression evaporates,
and as soon as the reality of the
situation asserts itself, once again,
it's amazing.
Satan falls headlong to his.